meet trench Kimball from San Antonio
Texas he's the head of a firm that makes
armored cars will take a common everyday
vehicle take out the entire interior and
put in our armored materials in the
doors the windows the roof the floor the
fuel tanks and basically make it a
cocoon of armor for the occupants inside
the vehicle these vehicles are going to
politicians businessmen celebrities and
even we've even armored them for the
Pope
one day Trent got so tired of people
asking him if the glass in his vehicles
could really stop a bullet
he decided to prove
the only time might have had a little
bit of fear enter my body was actually
looking at the shooter and the shooters
eyes got really big huh that's the only
time I actually felt a little bit
nervous shooting at my boss is actually
pretty interesting that there's a lot of
people would like to do it but I like my
boss is pretty cool so I'm glad he's
okay yes Trent lived and uploaded this
astonishing clip to the Internet where
it has almost 6 million hits but exactly
how did that windshield save his skin
the way you make glass absorb the energy
from something like an ak-47 is that you
have to make laminated glass so you'll
have a layer of glass and then you'll
have a layer of a material called
polycarbonate
then you'll have another layer of glass
and another layer of polycarbonate and
then so on and so on and so on to make a
thick window this is a composite and
composites are used when you want the
properties of two different materials
and you want to put them together for
different purposes if you were just to
have a thin piece of plastic a bullet
would easily penetrate that if you just
have a piece of glass the bullet would
cause it to completely shatter you put
those together and the glass disperses
that force of that bullet over a larger
area and then the plastic can absorb
that force aside from the ak-47 the m16
and other military type weapons we can
also stop the hand grenade and also
right up to the 50 caliber round so
thanks to the laminated glass
Trent dodged not one but three bullets
illegal semi-automatic rifle they're
really scary part was still to come
I did not tell my wife she she wasn't
gonna know until after now she says we
can't do it again holy crap